hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the world's
hardest game version 1.0 okay this is
actually a game that's pretty old and
infamous on the internet I played it a
long time ago didn't get very far but
not that I'm eager to try it again now
but you guys suggested in pretty much
the only other really really really
difficult game that I haven't played yet
besides the original I want to be the
guy and I don't want to even touch that
so since I have some prior experience
with this I'm gonna give it a try
uh I know I know what I'm getting into I
I do know that see what the objective is
to get this red thingy over to the green
so see that was easy because I am so
professional that I I'm not I'm not even
challenged by this game because a lot of
you don't understand this but I am
actually an extremely incredible gamer
of magnanimous skill maghen Mac yeah
haha see you guys don't understand just
how amazingly epic I am at some of these
games zero deaths I am I am incredible I
am oh boy this is what I stopped before
ah nothing nothing Ingo game eh wait do
I got to touch all the green one sir or
do I got it just are those just like
checkpoints or something okay my brain
is trying to wrap my head its head
around my brain is wrapping its own head
around this dude okay alright so good so
far
damn it my first death damn in my second
death
all right this is our death okay I'm
okay I can get this I was hoping to get
this get through this with no deaths at
all but looks like it won't be that
today but soon now give this track is
I'm just too good all these yeah yeah
yeah can't fool me
damn ha ha ha oh jeez ok as you can see
this is getting progressively harder but
not for me because ok so gotta go here
stop go stop go stop go go go go go go
go go go go
well those are going the wrong way how
am I supposed to be able to get them
there go the freaking wrong way ah ok
it's ok it's ok ok just gotta make a
circle Leeteuk come on this that is a
checkpoint I was wondering what that was
okay just got him somehow get through oh
I see I gotta go all the way back every
time I get a new one or I could just go
all the way forward and then go all the
way back and that probably means you
stop that I'm not touching it okay I
touched it that time but I wasn't before
just gotta stop go stop go stop go and
go up and then go stop go stop go stop
then do it all again okay stop go stop
go stop go stop go Oh to pro oh say
nothing this is like that level in the
beginning not gonna be hard you're hard
mom no uh stop making your mom jokes me
and get serious into the game here I
gotta get this this really hard I guess
that should be logical considering it is
the hardest game in the world apparently
okay did I get a checkpoint there I hope
maybe oh no I did not oh yes oh this is
where it starts
damnit what's the last time I played
this was like back in my freshman year
of college and and I was in a class in a
computer lab and I was just playing it
and my professor like caught me playing
and he came up I mean something like
where won't you play there I'm like oh
it's the hardest game in the world and I
was like on the third level he's like
you doesn't look so hard look nada it's
easy watch this and I died 50 times in a
row and everyone laughed at me because
he made he made me play for the class
that's what he was doing
I've almost got it everybody I've almost
got it just gotta get into here yeah
yeah
oh yeah what okay go go go no no no yeah
boy yeah buddy yeah buddy okay this
ain't so hard huh how the hell am I
supposed to be able to do this this
isn't dude I ran into it son of a
Wow yeah sounds like you get
punched in the dick every time you die
it's not cool
oh come on actually sounds like one of
those old school karate
oh how did I do this before I don't even
remember how do they do this
I ducked into one of these but it
doesn't seem like you can anymore okay
here we go no do this seriously how did
I do this how did I do this kid my brain
is not working anymore
this doesn't seem to be okay soon as I
know I can't do that how did I do this I
did it right the first time this is
impossible
okay there what you know this is
how did I do this how did I do this oh
my god did I oh I know what I did I know
what I did I know what I didn't know
okay i looped around no I didn't do that
I didn't do that but that's the way I'm
gonna do it now and it better like the
way that I'm gonna do it or else I'm
gonna shove my fist into its face and
then twirl it around a little bit until
he says hey get your fist out of my face
and then and we'll all go have a snack
down at
ah trying to get for telling a story
beside that's what I did the first time
now how did I do that what was that what
was that that I just did what did i do I
don't even know what I did hate the
techno music I hate that I love faster
than me that's not fair
you're not fair shut up world I hate me
I hate myself for picking on these games
oh hell hey I gotta go this way first
that's gotta be it it's not fair is that
fair
actually both sides are faster than me
oh how the heck gonna do this okay I got
that one I'm done I'm done right I'm
done good side the gone backing up I
would have been fine I don't know what
I'm doing I don't know what I'm doing
everybody hurry buddy welcome to my hell
my little personal slice of Hell where I
perpetually torture myself for your
entertainment good job everybody for
getting me into this sort of mess I
thought I was gonna do it I thought that
was gonna be the one it was not it was
not the one
not bit a little bad baby bad baby Oh
squirtle oh yes you heard me I got
squirtle there it's just not fair it's
not fair everybody is all my chance no
chance
oh crap I gotta get oh okay I just gotta
get over there right right right okay
I'm gonna wait for it to come back
around I got this I got this everybody
trust me I guess
nope not that one cuz the blue one was
coming so now here we go now now now now
no no no level 9 done level 9 level 9
yeah I'm doing it I'm doing it to it I'm
doing it I can't believe I'm doing it
okay
goddamn Oh walk right into the
stationary one of course hey oh yeah
wait what do I need to do here just
dodge these things do I need to get in
the orbs I see the one over there but do
anything else you learn he'll be me and
the gingerbread man oh I shoulda seen
that coming
y yep good dip doc yeah we play old days
do it you're better off this market
yes monkey yes yes in my ears
it's yeah oh yeah oh yeah just barely
away from it now now who's going to get
it I like how they all Wiggly the beat
blink blink good oh why do I walk into
the stationary ones that's not fair a
lot viral is always it this guy a visit
fair hodge-podge this is not going well
for me don't walk into the stationery I
hope that's a checkpoint I really do
glad school that seems close okey-dokey
let's not die all right but I like how
they're like barely touching me but
please they're not killing me right
that's the important thing
boink yeah boy yeah yeah boy all right
yeah got it good here getting good
footage here this really really really
oh god don't scrub these ones are easy
yes okay all right
oh yeah zip zap zoobi the battle sim is
a bazooka this his own jobs observer Doh
Dirac new leader oh this one's easy
this actually isn't too bad I'll be able
to get through this pretty easy there's
your stack
I always hit that I've killed myself
more in the stationary ones than
anything zip zap zip zip zap yeah yeah
these actually aren't that bad there's
just a lot of them so there's a lot of
room for error or not very much oh look
a lot a little I don't know either way
this one isn't as frustrating though at
least I know why I'm failing here and
it's my fault
cuz I mean the game is what it is but
it's not it's not Trixie's it's not
Trixie it's just I'm being an idiot I'm
in it I'm being an idiot sees that's
what it is I'm being dumb I'm too dumb
to beat this game I'm gonna get this
level though I need to get this level
down come on yeah don't touch the
stationary ones cuz I'm too proud to
touch those oh whoa Nelly okay just last
one okay alrighty
ah that tip would have been good a while
ago
harder than it looks but it probably
looks pretty hard a that oh well damn it
hey is it slowing down for me you're
right this is harder than it looks
ah I can't even get past the first one
because I'm an idiot yeah yeah dance
with it dance with it ah fudge with it
dance dance dance dance dance dance ah
ah not into it
come on boots and cats and boots and
cats and boots and cats and boots and
cats and boots and cats and this is it
isn't it fair I think I've said that
before I think I've I think I'm just
repeating my old commentary from before
gives you all we're wondering this isn't
very fair the problem with this is I'm
probably gonna never get past this
I'm never gonna beat this game for sure
because there's no save mechanic I don't
think there's a level skipper device so
that I could go wow I don't even think
it remembers where I've been
so I'm done this stupid I'm done this
game is impossible no one can beat it
anyone who does is a maniac with way too
much time on their hands
I'm other than opposed to me of course
he was a cool guy with you know gets all
the ladies wink
whatever so I'm done so I got 10 out of
32 see if you can do better thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos it I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video
ah
[Music]